no I don't think it's me I think the
idea of meanness is an incredibly
immature one on both sides I think that
if you are the subject of meanness and
you're upset by it because it hurts your
feelings then it's the wrong industry or
it's just you're reading it wrong you're
reading it for something other than its
intention and conversely if you are a
journalist and you are in media and you
make your living by being mean with no
substance you know it's like bad Indian
food where you're like this is just a
bunch of spices you know what happened
to the flavor Reena you're being me with
no substance well that's not real
journalism anyway so there's nothing to
get upset about you know I feel like
whenever either alleged victims of New
York snark or you know people or who are
purveyors of it get upset I think it's
because it's not actually what they do
you know you're not actually being
criticized for what you do and then when
they're doing it they're not actually
being journalists so I think it's pretty
easy to dismiss that element and the
only thing that's bad about it is if it
takes up the space of real criticism or
you know a real sort of interaction a
real sort of you know analysis of
entertainment which is always much more
fun and rewarding than person a just
kind of sucks I'm not going to tell you
why I just feel like maybe they should
be locked in a closet somewhere and
never come out
I became image data a long time ago and
of course like you know stuff still
hurts and like I said it's the level in
which you let it in it's the level of
what you let something bother you you're
like it's just a critique of what I'm
doing or some by someone who doesn't
know me but I one of my first pieces for
the village voice was what was it called
oh my god that's terrible i'm going
senile what oh but seriously it was good
that was the headline it was called but
seriously with 2 t's in the butt and it
was about white women with a larger than
normal amount of junk in their
respective trunks and you know mostly
got a good response have circulated on
the web but i got some letters into the
village voice that were called me a
racist and they were so they were well
worded to which is the worst thing that
anything that comes from a crazy person
can be you know because you forget you
think well if it's maybe they have a
point because they're using these s80
words and yeah i remember i sighed the
first time I read it I locked my office
door and I don't know I got a little
teary it was it was the most hurtful
thing and that sort of kind of
cauterized the wound a little bit though
because there were so many letters for
that piece and from people who seem to
just be waiting to be pissed off about
something and there's that element to
Gawker but I have to say I don't know
I'm kind of glad it exists I think that
it will be dangerous and I think it's
already coming to that time period when
people can't remember a time before it
exists before what did they look at
every morning when they came into their
offices before Gawker you know I don't
know CNN anything you know they'll be it
but it's they've actually been pretty
good to me to tell you the truth I think
that once they let the commenters on it
was very sort of a very interesting
dynamic that happened with the people
who actually edit the site because then
in addition to writing having the
responsibility of having to have a
just sort of phenomenal amount of the
output of just blog posts and witticisms
and things to comment on every day and
every hour they also have the
responsibility of directing people you
know here you go you either you hate
this person you don't hate this person
and you can see the sort of confusion
ensue if the if there's sort of non
partial pieces there have been a fair
amount of Narconon partial pieces about
me where you know is she banking on all
our connections she a good writer is she
a shitty writer you know what level of
attractiveness is she what level of
talent oisin you know that's not good or
bad those are questions and I guess it's
their right to pose do I blog no I don't
it's funny but some of my best friends
are bloggers honestly but no I mean
there's there's I don't have I mean it's
sort of it the good reason the
flattering towards the blogosphere
reason and it's also true it's just the
flattering part is that I think if I
have thoughts that are that worthwhile
don sort of worthwhile I'm sorry if I
have thought through that worthwhile and
culture in the state of media and the
state of you know Anna Wintour they're
going to be funneled into something
larger eventually I don't have them at
the frequency I've never kept a journal
I've never kept a diary and so I don't
think I could do that it is a skill and
I I don't have it or if I have it I just
feel like I can never be satisfied with
just that comment I want to know what
else is connected to it and you know it
either fizzles out in my brain or it
becomes something larger but I don't
blog myself I was once at a party full
of bloggers and the man who runs the
aforementioned site asked me if I had a
blog and this was ages ago this must
have been like Diana was like 2003 or
something like that and I just sort of
forgot where I was and I said oh god no
you're like the crickets chirp and the
record scratch but I mean they're all
really
they're really smart people I think that
if people get pissed off about Gawker or
blogs it's because you know it people
are using their powers other than the
subjects would wish them to but it's not
because they're idiots